joining me now is the governor of south
dakota christy gnome
christy thank you for joining us welcome
oh thank you rachel i sure appreciate
you having me on your show
absolutely so these blackouts that we're
seeing they're reminiscent of what we
saw in the
former soviet union in cuba in
california last summer
is this what we can expect in a you know
joe biden america that's pushing all
these green energy policies
well listen i've always been a supporter
of diversified energy i think it's a
critically important that we prioritize
all forms of energy biden has
specifically gone after
coal and oil and gas and i think that's
dangerous
we should be supporting energy that's
generated here in the united states so
we rely
on our own sources but also we don't put
all of our eggs in one basket we make
sure it is diversified so we don't have
the situation that we've got today in so
many different states
you know i'm a supporter of wind energy
but it's not consistent and that's why
you're always going to need other forms
of electricity
to support the system and the grid so
that families can make sure they can
keep their houses warm
absolutely um so tell me really quickly
because i know that
you know we're in the middle of this
pandemic um the keystone pipeline
uh that is one of the first things that
joe biden uh you know got rid of
so how is it affecting your state and
why the heck would he do that in the
middle of a pandemic when we don't
really have replacement jobs
what was interesting because the
pipeline was being built through the
state of south dakota
in fact they had already built a couple
of pumping stations they had the
pipeline laid out ready to be installed
and then when he pulled the permits
everything just stopped
there were so many families that have
told their stories in recent days about
the devastation to them and their
incomes and their businesses
we had restaurants and motels and gas
stations that had expanded
getting ready for the workers that were
going to be here for the next several
years building the pipeline they were
excited about the opportunities
to get the property taxes in these local
small schools
from the pipeline it was always going to
be a source of revenue that would help
them keep their roads fixed
keep commerce going and make sure that
their teachers could be well paid in a
lot of these remote areas where economic
development is a little challenging so
in overnight their whole plan for the
future
was just gone and i think for a lot of
families in the state of south dakota it
was devastating for me in particular
i see all sides of it as well it was a
critical piece of infrastructure that
gave us
energy in this country and made sure
that we were going to be able to deliver
it
efficiently and safely and protect the
environment listen this pipeline was
safer for the environment than how we're
moving this oil today
it was safer for people truck line and
it was going to bring down the cost
of gas and oil in this country which is
so important to those hard-working
families that
that try to pay their bills every month
so governor you're not just
you know a politician you're not just a
governor you're also a rancher
and you know that we had that interview
with bill gates earlier
he says that we need to stop um eating
beef so i want you to see this clip but
i want to come back on the other side
with you on that
this company nature's find is using
fungi
and then they turn them into sausage and
yogurt pretty amazing when you say fungi
do you mean like a mushroom or a microbe
it's a microbe so how would
fungi micro burgers go over in south
dakota
well i mean i like mushrooms but i like
my beef too
so and south dakota
the cattle industry is incredibly
important to our state of course but
here's
here's the situation is that he talks a
lot about carbon emissions out of cattle
but he doesn't take into account the
carbon emissions
and the inefficiencies in generating
food like that and how expensive that
food would be
for the average everyday family so you
know beef and protein is incredibly
important it's also important that a
family can go to the grocery store
and afford the food that they need to
put on their table to take care of their
kids
and that's the balance that i don't
think bill gates understands
is that for me food policies always been
national security policy
it's important that we grow our own food
in this country so another country
doesn't control us
it's also important that it's
diversified so that we don't have
a shortage in one area we focus all in
one area and it becomes too expensive
for families to actually go to the store
buy it and put it on the table
i want to talk to you a little bit about
the future of the gop there seems to be
this battle here right where you have
the mitch mcconnell liz cheney adam
kinzinger's side of the
of the party who's saying we need to you
know forget trump we need to move on we
need to change the republican party
um but i live not very far from where
you live and that's certainly not what
i'm hearing um
out there so tell me what you think
i think what people want is a republican
party that actually
follows through on what they say they're
going to do that
actually puts forward and enacts the
policies that we say we believe in
we talked for years about doing health
care reform repealing obamacare and we
haven't done it we've talked about doing
immigration reform
making sure that we're welcoming people
legally to this country and we haven't
done it
so that's what i think the last several
years should teach republicans
is that we're tired of politicians we're
tired of people that stand up and give
speeches and never take action that's
what the last administration did is they
took action
and people realized that they liked that
and they liked the benefits of people
who actually were public servants
you know i told people that i was going
to have you on the show today and a lot
of people want to know if you're going
to run for president
oh i'm running for reelection to be
governor of south dakota
so i'll be up for re-election in 2022
and i'm hoping
the people of the state will will trust
me again to lead the state for another
four years
it's a special place you know i want to
talk to you really quick
also about a lot of people out there are
frustrated with with the government
that's how you got into government
can you very quickly tell us why you got
into government and why that personal
tragedy really got you to get moving in
there
yeah well uh what happened was um
i was going to college and my dad was
killed in an accident he was 49 years
old at the time actually the same age
that i
am now and was killed and i came home
and took over the family businesses
but within weeks we were notified that
we owed death taxes
and we owed the federal government a
bunch of money because we had a tragedy
in our family
so it made me mad i tell people all the
time that i just decided that i was
going to start showing up at meetings
i had been raised by a dad who was a
cowboy who just said you don't complain
about things you fix them
and i realized i needed to start showing
up and if i wanted different laws
different policies that i needed to be
there
and be a business person a mom someone
who actually gave my perspective if
there's one thing that i've learned
since i've been in public office is that
you get better bills you get better laws
you get better policies when you have a
diversity of opinions around the table
when you have men women people of
different backgrounds and cultures
they're having the discussion and the
debate
you will end up with a better law that
serves people
much better into the future so my hope
is that more women will run
that more average people at home that
are running businesses will
sit at that table show up at that
meeting and contribute because that's
really how we fix what's wrong with this
country
yeah we need people who really know what
it's like to to you know
run a family and and have kids and and
pay bills
i'm running for office christy known
governor gnome it is such a pleasure to
have you on today i want to thank you so
much and i'm sure that you're inspiring
so many people who are watching right
now thank you oh
thank you rachel all right coming up
president